Studying while battling depression is one of
the hardest things to do
It's difficult enough getting out of bed
but depression steals away your energy
motivation and concentration
It's like having a cloudy memory and
struggling to survive each and every day.
How can you possibly get through school
while dealing with depression?
One : Use a planner
Depression leads to disorganization and
foggy memory
In school, it's critical to remember when
you have assignments, presentations and tests
Bring a planner with you to your classes and
write down everything you need to remember
So you won't forget anything or
end up brushing an assignment last minute
Two: Study and do homework on time
Studying without motivation is hard
But by doing a little every day,
you can lower your stress levels .
There may be days when studying feels impossible
But if you studied a bit every day before that
it's okay to take a day off once in a while
when things get really rough
When you have depression
having some free time to rest is essential
Three: Space it out
Divide your study material into small chunks and
review it continuously over long periods of time
This will increase your chances of learning the material
Additionally, review each lesson
before starting a new one
Four: Don't pull all-nighters
By staying up all night,your depression will worsen and the symptoms will become more severe
Suicidal thoughts may also increase drastically
Instead, organize your schedule in a way
where you're not staying up all night to
complete your assignments
Five: Take breaks
Don't study or do homework for hours on end
Depression lowers your energy
And if you don't take breaks in between study sessions, you will burn out
The trick is to study for 30-minute intervals with
10-minute breaks in between
Everyone's a little different though
so test out different time schedules to
see what works best for you
and adjust the intervals accordingly
Six: Keep a binder or notebook
People with depression can have trouble
staying organized
By buying binders or notebooks
and using dividers,
it's easy to separate your study materials
This will allow you to
feel less overwhelmed
Seven: Stay away from negative people
It's already hard enough to
stay optimistic with depression
So surrounding yourself with
pessimistic people won't help you
it'll bring you down and
affect your school performance
Remember : you are studying so
you can have a career you love
so spend time with people
who support you and
push you towards your goals when life gets hard
Eight: Consume brain foods
Depression makes you crave junk food
and even though it's okay to
treat yourself every now and then
don't make a habit out of it
Instead, stay away from sugars
Stay hydrated and eat nutritious food
which will increase your energy and
improve your focus
Nine: Find a study buddy
Figure out which one of your classmates
is more responsible and stick to them
Create study groups where
you can ask each other questions
But be careful of lazy students who
may try to use you
as their pessimistic nature will affect your mood
Ten: Highlight
People with depression can easily feel overwhelmed
especially when they're taking a course
with lots of material
When you feel stuck
buy different color highlighters to
divide the material by main topic,
subtopic,
important information etc
Eleven: Take care of yourself and find hobbies
If all you do is study,
you'll feel more depressed
so don't forget to treat yourself
Take some time to pursue hobbies and
practise self-care
to improve your overall mood
Watch a movie or
eat at your favorite restaurant
Have fun with friends,
take a breather
and then you can continue studying
Society puts a lot of pressure on students
especially when it comes to their studies
Remember : your mental health comes first and
grades don't define you
Failing a course doesn't make you a failure
We're all human
so don't feel bad if you need to
take a break
to regain your mental health
How are your experiences with school ?
Do you have any other tips that may be helpful?
Let us know in the comments below
If you enjoy this video
be sure to check out our website
as well as our other social media and
don't forget to subscribe
Thanks for watching
You